the city of parkland Florida is holding
a moment of silence today to remember
the victims of the mass shooting at
Marjory Stoneman Douglas High School it
was two years ago today that a gunman
opened fire killing 17 people now active
shooter drills are conducted at nearly
every American public school vladimir
duthiers is here with how the nation's
two largest teachers unions want to
change the way these drills are carried
out vlad good morning so what do they
want to change that's right Tony the
National Education Association the
American Federation of Teachers and the
gun safety advocacy group every town
released a report this week calling for
an end to drills that surprised students
and the use of firearms and actors as
victims to demonstrate possible active
shooters in America schools in a moment
it's a little nerve-racking and pretty
scary hunter now it's active shooter
drills happen at least twice a year at
the Neptune New Jersey high school where
Charlie's Kepler is a freshman thank you
we met up with Charlie's and her mom
Beth at their local coffee shop a lot of
schools are conducting these active
shooter drills sadly how do you feel
about it I feel sad that they're
necessary but as a parent it makes me
feel comfortable that there's something
being done and
a tool being given to the children who
are sitting there vulnerable to feel
like they can do something to empower
themselves to protect themselves the
drill at Sharlee school last fall
sparked immediate controversy in her
community and school districts
nationwide no one should ever support
doing something just because you feel
like well we have to do something so
let's do this when what you're doing
could actually cause trauma and fear for
those children Lili Eskil s'en Garcia is
the president of the National Education
Association the NEA wants to end drills
where weapons are drawn and actors play
roles as victims sometimes covered with
fake blood one of the things we know is
not helpful is to have an active
realistic shooter drill that can
frighten terrorize traumatize the big
people in the little people in that
school the NEA also wants to notify
teachers students and parents in advance
of active shooter drills in 2018 CBS
this morning aired a live pre-planned
shooter drill with a group of Ohio
fourth graders even with notification
and television cameras in their
classroom students revealed how
frightening the experience could be who
here is scared when they go through
these drills would you want that advance
notice no why because I feel that in
that moment that the children are
training I think that they should be
thinking and treating it as if it's real
just like a fire drill fire drills are
expected to be treated as if they're
real because it's gonna save your life
as for Charlie's the active shooter
drills are not traumatic they're typical
my generation has grown up with these
active shooter drills we don't see it as
something that is
so terrifying and is extreme as some of
the older generations because it's just
kind of like how we've grown up and live
the kepler's do agree with one of the
changes that teachers unions would like
to see and that is providing students
with school-based mental health
assistance it's such an interesting
question I mean I can I can I see both
sides of this I really do the schools
feel they have to do something because I
don't want to be you know have be
flat-footed but on the other hand is
there evidence that this is working no
and I can totally see how it would
traumatize some kids especially young
children yeah just even by watching the
news you see it happening it's covered
it's it's traumatizing either way all
right blood thank you